we're going to begin with this president
biden is preparing to mark 100 days in
office this week with a variety of
events including
his first speech to a joint session of
congress and a drive-in rally in georgia
a new cbs news poll finds 65 percent of
americans approve of how he's handling
this pandemic
the president set several goals when he
entered the white house including
requiring mass where he is legally able
to like at federal buildings
and during interstate travel while masks
are still required in those areas
some states have taken a very different
approach in fact at least
13 states have lifted their mass mandate
orders
only 26 states now require you to wear a
mask
in public the president also said an
initial goal of 100 million vaccine
doses administered in his first 100 days
in office
before increasing that goal to 200
million and that number was achieved
last week we are now at nearly
229 million doses administered as for
who has gotten at least one dose
64 percent are white 12 percent are
hispanic
more than 8 percent are black and more
than 5 percent are
asian and a new cbs news poll finds
22 percent of americans say they will
not get the vaccine
at all new data from the kaiser
foundation suggests
vaccine supply will likely outweigh
demand in the coming weeks
dr ashish shah the dean of brown
university school of public health joins
us now dr john good morning to you
good morning thanks for having me back
we always appreciate you being on we
have a new survey out a new poll from
cbs
showing that about a quarter to a fifth
to a quarter of americans say they will
not
get a vaccine of any kind that is a big
improvement in fact from february the
number is getting smaller
is it small enough
yeah i think it will get smaller yet i'm
hopeful and part of it is a lot of those
people
i think are still waiting and seeing and
if that number diminishes further
then it will be good enough we don't
need to have every american vaccinated
but we do need to have
most and i hope i hope most americans
decide this is really a safe and
effective vaccine that
is good for them it's good for their
families we've also learned from the cdc
that about 5 million americans have not
returned to get their second vaccination
so one of the moderna
or pfizer shots is one shot good enough
does that provide any
protection for people yeah one shot is
definitely not good enough
it's very very clear from the data that
people need both shots
and so what i say to people is if you
miss your second shot don't worry about
it go back and get it now
there's no problem in in having it been
delayed a little bit
but it is critical that everybody get
their second shot because
that's the only way we know that it's
going to really protect you for
any extended period of time dr xia you
wrote in an
op-ed recently that the u.s has
strategic interests
to help india manage uh the coronavirus
crisis there which is escalating in
alarming proportions right now
what more should the u.s do do you think
yeah i think the u.s can do a lot and
even since i've written that op-ed the
president and
the federal government has come out in
strong support of acting i think it's
fabulous we should be helping them with
their hospital supplies with
testing and also helping them ramp up
vaccinations you know we have
so many vaccines right now that i think
we should be sending excess supply
especially of vaccines that we're not
using here
to india to help india out at this
moment
you know i think it's important to to
emphasize how important it is to help
other countries when the
coronavirus first started we we were
told
if you if you haven't been to china
don't know anybody who's come from china
you don't really need to worry about it
and we see how quickly
this has spread so i i think it's
important emphasize
what happens in other parts of the world
really does affect us eventually don't
you think
yeah absolutely this is a global
pandemic we know for instance that when
you see new variants arise
anywhere it ends up on our shores very
quickly
we are really all in this together and
if we're going to get through this
pandemic
we've all got to help each other bring
the pandemic under control the cdc says
they're thinking about
adjusting the guidelines for masks that
we may not have to wear them outside
where do you stand on that do you think
it's time to rethink how
and where and when we wear our mask
you know absolutely gail we we have
learned over the last year that there's
relatively little spread outdoors
especially if you're not packed together
in large groups
so i expect the cdc to come out with new
guidance on this and i expect a lot of
states
to begin to peel back outdoor mask
mandates i think
that's probably pretty reasonable we've
got to keep indoor mass mandates
in for a little bit longer that is where
most of the spread is happening but
uh pulling back on outdoor stuff does
seem pretty reasonable at this moment
all right dr jaw and the other uh thing
in the in the near future is the fall
start of school once again do you expect
children to be
available for vaccinations at that point
well first of all i think all kids
should be back in school this fall and i
think they will be
teachers have all been vaccinated
schools are really a safe place for kids
to go back i expect
older kids to be vaccinated by the fall
i think
young kids under 12 probably not but
i i don't think that should slow us down
at all from getting everybody back in
school this fall
all right well the possibility of not
having to wear a mask outdoors during
the summer and not getting a masked tan
i like that possibility dr shisha
thank you very much we appreciate it
thank you